you were talking earlier about this
something horse the lead horse oh
beating a dead horse no no it was a lead
horse she said there's a guy that you
fancy right now yeah um what are you
doing to try to win over the lead
horse I put in effort honestly I what
kind of effort I'll ask like I know a
lot of girls who are like I don't make
the first move I don't do this I I let
the butt guys chase me and like I'm
that's kind of like my vibe too sh
advice by the way that's how you stay
single
I don't do that like I don't mind I will
I will chase back um but I guess my
thing is like you know every once in a
while be like oh like are you like I'm
not doing it like I'll kind of ask them
out I guess or ask them to hang out or
I'll start the conversation I don't do
that I'm gonna wait for him to text me I
mean sometimes I do I play the game but
I'm what about the notion of doing
something useful uh for him you know
being useful in his life inviting him
over to display your culinary skills you
make them a nice meal yeah that's I so I
live on my own um a lot of not a lot
well most of the guys that I've like
talked to they like live with their
parents so I do always offer I'm like oh
like if um because I understand like
money is a struggle so I don't expect
dates I kind of just like want like
quality time so I will I'll be like oh
like let's get so like for an example
the guy that I'm talking to now with
Christmas coming up I was like oh like
let's go get some of those Pillsbury
cookies
and
then sorry her dog is munching on I was
like we'll go get some pillsberry
cookies and watch Christmas movies like
that kind of stuff so I have like and I
can cook I ran a restaurant for about
three years well run it but
um so I love I love cooking for people
that is one of my biggest and favorite
things to do and I do that all the time
if I can because everyone right but I
mean like you're talking about doing
like Pillsbury cookies and Netflix and
show like that's not that's not feeding
a
man you would you would be surprised how
easy it is to gain uh much stronger
desire and interest out of a guy if you
can show him that that you can feed him
well if you meal prep for them Ken I'm
telling you I hey that's another way to
do it too I mean if the guy is training
for something or trying to you know
doing something at Dojo you prepare
meals for the week when I'm in a
relationship I'm very like uh if they
have to go somewhere far to go pick up
parts or car parts or they're working on
their car I'm like yeah I'll come and
sit and like sit there support you be
your you know hang out give you some
company come with you for the drive or
no no I think you're Miss some point I
think I am
missing it's talking about adding some
value to his life like being useful to
him you know in some regard like if you
want a man to choose you like if you
want a man to invite you into his life
because men are the men are The
Gatekeepers of a of when a relationship
happens women are The Gatekeepers of
when sex happens right like you're going
to decide when that part of
the equation comes together he's going
to decide when you know like it's why
men propose to women right so like
you're asking me like what I have to
offer no what I'm asking you is you know
if he's a lead horse what is it that
you're doing to try to be useful to his
life so that he chooses you you know
aside from pills cookies because I mean
you've got amazing culinary skills why
not invite him over and feed him a
fantastic meal so I have that's one of
the things we've already that's already
happened I guess like I date and like as
far as the car parts go like he doesn't
really need a guy riding shotgun
watching while he's doing his thing it's
like if he needs car parts and maybe say
hey why don't I go pick it up for you
and I'll bring it over you know so that
you can save the time and you know I'll
help you install it or hold the light or
something like that yeah no and I do and
I and like I would say like I am like
that once I'm in a relationship but I
also don't give a man wife if I'm not
his girlfriend you know what I mean like
I'll put in the effort till we get there
but like once we're there like you get a
whole different like you get you get
more out of me so when I go out to test
drive a car I want the car to perform
the same way that it's going to perform
when I have bought it so I want a real
feel for it like I don't want it to have
like 60% reduced uh Power and 70%
shittier fuel economy or any of those
things like I want it to be exactly how
it's going to be while it's with me so
it's the same sort of thing you know
when when you're dating like if you want
a guy to choose you like if you want
want him to pick you over his other
options I'm assuming he probably has
other options if you're chasing him then
why not be useful to his life you know
like sort of like step into that role of
girlfriend without him you know having
made the invitation I mean at some point
you you will need to say Hey you know
like where do we stand like where's this
going right we're not there yet I think
you're fa where I'm at fair enough but I
mean like you should still be doing
things to win him over is what I'm
saying right because the most valuable
thing that that that guys want from from
a relationship that keeps uh him wanting
to go back to a woman is if she's useful
to him like if she adds value to his
life but I've done that like for example
with my current partner like I have
always been one to like cuz I'm a mother
so obviously I'm already cooking I'm
already cleaning I'm already doing the
laundry I'm doing everything that a wife
would be expected to kind of do I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out